welcome back to CBS morning's the new
year will bring a wave of changes on
Capitol Hill speaker Nancy Pelosi will
enter decades-long service as a
congressional leader Republicans will
take control of the U.S house and 55
lawmakers will leave their current
positions after making the decision not
to run for re-election among them
congresswoman Jackie Speer 44 years ago
she was left for dead at an airstrip in
a South American jungle after an ambush
Jonestown cult members killed her boss
shocked the world and ultimately shaped
her future Scott McFarland sat down with
her on Capitol Hill
decades before coming to Congress Jackie
Speer was lying on a deserted airstrip
in the small South American nation of
Guyana with five bullet wounds I was on
that airstrip for 22 hours without
medical attention on the ground on the
ground Congressman Leo Ryan of
California is dead shot along with four
other Americans Speer was then a 28 year
old Congressional staffer on a
fact-finding mission with her boss
California Congressman Leo Ryan at the
people's Temple compound of leader Jim
Jones after the visit as they sought to
return home attackers dispatched by the
cult leaders assassinated Ryan
shot spear multiple times many of us
thought we were just gonna you know die
there I was thinking that you know no
one would ever know my family would
never know what happened to me shortly
after another horror unfolded when
hundreds of men and women in the
people's Temple died in an act of mass
murder suicide the scene at Jonestown
assaults the senses almost defies
description spear Gravely injured was on
the ground a few miles away praying for
the arrival of a rescue chopper I think
it's informed everything I've done I
mean it's made me into a fighter and to
not take no for an answer I do
congratulations she fought for and won
Leo Ryan's old congressional seat in
2008. one of the biggest things about
Jackie is it's not it's not about
fighting for political ideology it's
it's fighting for people Aaron Ryan once
served as a staffer to spear she sees
something wrong and feels a compulsion a
need to do something about it Aaron Ryan
is also the daughter of Leo Ryan when
you describe the congresswoman and you
described your dad sounds like you're
describing the same person yeah
I am
absolutely I am spear would gain
notoriety for two fights in particular
she secured a spot on the house armed
services committee after learning about
serious flaws in the system to protect
service members against sexual assault
within the ranks
from her position she would Grill
military officials sexual assault and
harassment will not be tolerated we pay
your bills we fund you
the game is over and in 2017 amid an
emerging sexual harassment Scandal on
Capitol Hill it was Speer who testified
and detailed a pervasive culture of
unwanted advances I have had numerous
meetings and phone calls with staff
members both president and former women
and men who have been subjected to this
inexcusable and oftentimes illegal
Behavior Republicans have bristled at
some of Spear's other ideas and tactics
her maiden speech on the house floor
elicited some booze as she railed
against the Iraq War suggests we could
be in Iraq for a hundred years
but Madam speaker history
[Applause]
and it was spear who first pushed the
idea of invoking the 25th Amendment
against then president Donald Trump in
2017 after his response to the white
nationalist rally in Charlottesville
spear who faced death in the jungle in
1978 says she committed to her family a
few years ago to finally step away from
Congress to remain full-time in
California to leave the seat she and her
former boss held for nearly two decades
combined everyone looks at Guyana as
this horrific yes it was horrific but my
God I had a second chance at life
and it's made me Fearless
which I probably would not have been had
I not had that experience I mean when
you look death in the eye you are not
afraid anymore
Jackie spear is leaving Congress after a
half century in politics beginning as a
volunteer on a State Legislative
campaign when she was a teenager her
final day here is Monday January 2nd
flat
a remarkable life well lived Scott thank
you very much you know I love what she
says at the end of Scott's piece where
she talks about the her horror that
Jonestown was but finding a career in
public service you would think that you
would want to shy away public life from
anything of course like that and she
dive right into it and she has a career
fighting for people who were victimized
the metoo movement she brought to
Congress and she helped pass the
Congressional accountability act which
provided mandatory training for staffers
changed the way survivors are treated
and made sure I love this that interns
have the same protections as full-time
staff and she said I had a second chance
at life and that made me Fearless like
let her life be an example you don't
have to face death necessarily but if
you have a second chance at anything
just be Fearless you go through that
trial by fire and you come out of it
forged that's what Jackie Spears did
most remarkable career remarkable life